[Music]
we should all try to eat as healthy as
possible but for many of us that means
eliminating sugar from our diet but it's
quite hard when there are some foods
that contain way more sugar than you
think it's enough to put you off them
stay until the end when we'll show you
just how much sugar is in a glass of one
healthy-looking soft drink if you
haven't visited us with the things
before please click the subscribe button
and give this video a like today we're
going to take a look at ten foods you'll
never eat again after knowing how much
sugar is in them coca-cola coca-cola is
the most iconic soft drink in the world
it's classic font and it's red and white
color scheme are instantly recognizable
so much so that you might even forget
that it's there however as much as we
all like a drop of the stuff every now
and then we don't think you should drink
it too often why well that's because it
has a really high level of sugar just
one 330 milliliter can contains about 35
grams of the stuff for comparison that
is roughly the equivalent of 7 teaspoons
of sugar makes you think right so next
time why not pass or try a glass of
water instead low fat yogurts something
that a lot of people enjoy after a meal
is a yogurt a good yogurt is smooth
creamy and absolutely delicious now with
a bean and dairy products you might be
worried about how healthy it is overall
so that might make you decide that you
want to have a low-fat yogurt with lots
of fruit in it but be careful many
yogurt makers use fruit from preserves
which breaks up the sugar content quite
dramatically
the typical 8 ounce carton of the food
typically contains 45 grams worth of
sugar that's three times as much as a
plain yogurt so you might well just want
to think again before you take the
low-fat option freshly squeezed fruit
juice a nice cold refreshing glass of
freshly squeezed fruit juice sounds like
it should be really healthy well yes and
no the thing is is that it will contain
a lot of the same health benefits as
eating a piece of fruit that's good but
what's bad is it takes out a lot of the
fiber that's in the fruit
it's not just that we should get as much
fiber in our diet as you can it's also
that fruit naturally contains a lot of
sugar which fiber soaks up without that
you get hit with an awful lot of sugar
as much as 36 grams in some cases you'd
be better just eating the fruit and
having a glass of water Thompson's
seedless raisins Thompson's seedless
raisins known as sultanas in some
countries are a staple ingredient in
many kitchens they are tasty and they
are a very useful thing to put in a cake
but how do you ever put them on your
breakfast or had a handful as a healthy
snack well what we are going to tell you
might just make you think again you see
a quarter cup of the dried grapes
contains a whopping 28 grams if you want
to eat a healthy snack try regular
grapes yes they've got a lot of sugar in
them but they also have a high water
content you need they'll fill you up
more instant oatmeal oatmeal is in and
of itself a tasty and nutritious food
stuff a bowl of it can be the perfect
way to start the day however be careful
that you use the real thing it might be
an idea to avoid the instant variety of
what people in the UK call porridge
that's because instant oatmeal has far
more sugar in it than you might think
some brands have more than 14 grams per
packet that's about two teaspoons of
sugar for something that you wouldn't
necessarily consider a sweet food if you
want to save your teeth and help your
diet - then you're going to have to get
rid of the instant oatmeal you'll have
to cook the stuff from scratch green
smoothies one of the most fashionable
things to have to start the day these
days is the green smoothie it's like a
regular smoothie but as well as fruit
there are vegetables in it usually it's
spinach and the ubiquitous kale that are
added to the drink however don't think
that because it's green it's
automatically healthier you see while
the vegetables make of a green the
majority of the drink still comes from
fruit and while fruit is very good for
you it still contains a lot of sugar
just one glass of these things can
contain a massive 32 grams of sugar
you'd be better off just eating the food
because then at least it'll fill you up
more soy milk
back in the day there was only really
one kind of milk it came from cows and
it was delivered to your door early in
the morning
by a whistling milkman while the ancient
trade of milk delivery is sadly dying
out milk isn't scientists were able to
create milk using vegetables grains and
nuts these are good for people who are
lactose intolerant and who want to cut
animal products from their diet however
what some of them are not so good for is
maintaining a low sugar lifestyle in soy
milk for instance it contains a teaspoon
of sugar for every 500 milliliters if
you don't want to make the change
oat milk is just as nice and very low in
sugar cansu the simple can of soup is a
wonder of the consumer age it's turned
to food that was quite time-consuming to
make into something you can put in the
hob or the microwave and eat straight
away pretty much every kitchen in the
Western world will have a can of the
stuff and it's even been turned into art
legendary New York artist Andy Warhol's
paintings of Campbell's soup cans turn
them into an icon however while we agree
there's nothing like a bowl of soup on a
cold day it might not be that healthy
for you that is because sugar is added
as a preservative a cup of soup can have
up to 15 grams of sugar in it so be
careful Poe mill bread bread is perhaps
the single staple food of the Western
world since the dawn of time the
combination of flour and water heated up
has filled stomachs it's something that
many people eat every single day to
Beach stands they might won't have
forgotten they eat it and that might be
where the problem could be you see son
bread contains a surprising amount of
sugar this is especially true of
wholemeal bread Baker's sometimes add
sugar to it to help mask the bitter
taste
and while wholemeal generally contains
more fiber it's still worrying that some
rands have as much as half a teaspoon of
sugar per slice so our advice is to make
sure you aren't buying bread with high
sugar content Odwalla Odwalla is a
household name across the United States
of America its range of tasty and
ethically produced drinks make it a
go-to products for a lot of people when
it started off in 1980 the Californian
company and to create drinks that are
both healthy and organic however as time
went on the firm started to add sugar to
their products okay
it was cane sugar which is in process
but it's still sugar and in there
strawberry seemed
mr. smoothy's he can find 41 grams of
sugar in a glass in their serious
tropical energy drink it's 44 grams that
said we'll still drink it because it
tastes nice and it's ethically sourced
what made us wonder what's your guilty
pleasure tell us in the comments and
that's all for our ten foods you'll
never eat again after knowing how much
sugar is in them we hope you enjoyed
watching it if you did why not check out
ten foods you'll never buy again after
knowing how they are made
thanks for watching and don't forget to
subscribe
[Music]